regardez j'espère que vous avez vu des
chaînes mais regardez comment un
influent mais aujourd'hui plaide encore
dans notre eau proisy millénaire est ce
que c'est possible
est ce que c'est normal
cela fait plus de trente ans que
grégoire a hobo non brise les chaînes
des personnes souffrant de maladies
mentales en afrique de l'ouest
de passage à montréal il parle de ses
sans voix car au bénin au togo en côte
d'ivoire encore aujourd'hui ils sont
enchaînés à des arbres car leurs
familles pensent qu'ils sont possédés
par les démons alors qu'il souffre de
schizophrénie ou de bipolarité
c'est la maladie mentale celle acquise
au frisbee pollet c'est la dépression
il suffit qu'un mâle enquête commence a
dit j'entends des voix
je vois des choses bizarres je vois des
serpents je vois des gens qui veulent me
fait du mal à le tout de suite c'est la
sas et les scènes possession il ya un
grand travail à faire ce travail
grégoire s'y consacre depuis des
décennies
l'association 5ème y voit le jour en
côte d'ivoire avant de s'étendre au
bénin et au togo
tu prends quelqu'un damon dans la rue il
faut d'abord le nettoyer il faut d'abord
le laver la bille et le redonner la
dignité de sa personne il faut pas voir
la maladie
il faut voir l'homme notre travail c'est
surtout les aimer l'amour et la
confiance
il est plus facile de vivre avec les
malades mentaux que de vivre avec les
bien portants et selon lui une fois
prise en charge
il faut leur confier des responsabilités
c'est en 2001 après la diffusion d'un
reportage à radio canada que
l'association prend de l'ampleur et que
les amis de la saint camille au québec
sont créés et ses amis sont là fidèles
au rendez vous une fois qu'il a été pris
dans la rue traité et que ces gens-là
ensuite son sens son secrétaire puissent
être aient des aides soignants
infirmiers c'est inouï pour nous ici on
n'a pas tendance à donner des
responsabilités qui compte autant des
gens qu'ils avaient encore lieu des 2
vireux séjour de dix jours au québec
bien remplie pour grégoire avec
plusieurs conférences dont une de vendée
psychiatre à l'hôpital douglas on les
enchaîne des apps ou la plus sous le
soleil là il ya des gens qui ont fait 8
en 1 et le traitement consiste à
souffler le corps ou que le diable sort
il faut les priver de nourriture le kg
les mois je m'appelle grégoire son
message est bien entendu mais la maladie
mentale est encore loin d'être une
priorité pour beaucoup les organismes
internationaux s'intéressent pas
beaucoup malades mentaux et c'est ça les
difficultés que nous rencontrons ce qui
explique qui a pas beaucoup bougé ou
d'associations en afrique qui
s'intéresse aux malades mentaux des
coûts des médicaments
ici à l'organisme collaboration santé
internationale à québec
grégoire récupère des équipements
désuets des hôpitaux
depuis sa fondation plus de soixante
mille malades ont non seulement été
soigné par la saint camille mais ils ont
aussi été réintégré dans le milieu du
travail
que t'inspire énorme qui est en congé
mais c'est l'humanité qui est paru gêné
c'est l'humanité qui est un chat mais il
s'est fait battre le coeur qui sera du
canada montréal